[Musique]
ce soir
obama demande avant tout c'est que
samantha
mais chouette avec
[Applaudissements]
merci
et thomas je voulais me confier à toi
voilà j'étais partie sur du gris il
était alors alors je l'espère je suis
arrivé ici à 16 heures à 16 heures
j'étais blond à 17 heures j'étais
fuchsia à 18 heures le coiffeur me dit
tu vas pas que je repasse sa couleur
initiale il dit frère tu sais que j'ai à
prendre ou à laisser donc à lui tu crois
vraiment que ça va prendre
et il paraît que le succès est venu
tellement vite que t'es pas passé loin
du burn out c'est ce qu'on avait dit
parce que j'étais en plein dedans trait
comtois me suis ramassé la gueule comme
en ski libre à supporter les hôtels de
luxe j'ai pas supporté voilà ce monde
ces trucs un peu étranger qui n'était
pas le mien tout simplement tu vois
esquissé à la réunion je suis vraiment
parti en la 3g pas supporter pourquoi
parce que c'est compliqué parce que
c'est pas rien parce qu'il faut toujours
être beau futur est présentable couture
bien par les aventures faire les choses
que tu vois et puis parfois j'ai alors
que je fais je fais mais je fais pas
attention je suis comme je suis je suis
je fais pas de manière je connais
personne ne l'a pressenti au milieu
c'était sûr loin de ma campagne quoi tu
vois c'est ça un peu maintenant c'est
cool maintenant je suis content je me
suis habitué je rigole j'ai plus peur de
vous
[Rires]
il ya une rumeur qui a enflé avec wave
des nantais les fans sont communs sur
cette rumeur on conseille de nombreux
jeunes
peut-être il faut dire que vous a vu
faire des vidéos ensemble elle était
même chez toi mais quand même
et qu'est ce qui se passe avec quoi on
ne se passe rien c'est juste ont fait
début en fait c'est comme on est souvent
les gens nous voient souvent ensemble et
il aime trop s'imaginer des couples et
familles allaient bien on s'imagine tout
cas aucun délit n'a rien rien on n'a
rien quoi je deviens viron on aime bien
aussi enjoué
[Musique]
ce qui se passe mais chut qu'est ce qui
se passe je sois attendait 6 ou payants
qui le finançaient me plaît s'il vous
plaît
qu'est ce qui se passe dans le public
oui merci on n'est pas là pour juste
faire du scandale ou pour faire du sport
nous sommes des maîtres d'hôtels d'accor
voilà une reprise on tourne les
précaires de les extras en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui pour la plupart sont rsa le
mois prochain on sera le double au rsa
je ne sais pas pourquoi on est on nous a
sortis du système
aujourd'hui nous fonctionner comme des
intermittents du spectacle nous avons
nous voulons de l'événementiel vos
cocktails tout les laisserait sa longue
on enfin tout ce qui était que celles ci
concernent avec ces mêmes l'ailé les
rapports des cocktails du gouvernement
c'est nous qu'ils en l'occupant et
aujourd'hui on nous a totalement lâché
nous n'avons plus rien des jours noirs
depuis mars et c'est bien dans ce sens
aller ce soir n'attend pas des miracles
cette émission se contentant de donne la
parole ça me fera dans btp jeudi soir
n'a aucun souci on vous donnera la
parole d'exclues pour plusieurs familles
des villages impactés par la tempête
alex ce soir on appeler notre partenaire
les magasins but voilà et nous avons
décidé d'offrir 25000 euros
d'ameublement et d'électroménager aux
sinistrés de la polémique
avec tout le nécessaire matelas canapés
tables fauteuils mais également du gru
et petit électroménager réfrigérateur
gazinière micro-ondes cécile voilà on a
on essaie de faire le maximum mais il
faut vraiment essayer de vous aider et
que tout le monde se mobilisent parce
que j'espère que c'est un vrai drame
j'espère que ça sera l'agglo qui va
faire démarrer leur montrent un nuage je
sais qu'éric ce qui arrive cela fait but
c'est un enfant du village le sait on le
soutient à fond si dans son initiative
[Musique]
pour sa chronique urbaine ou dire le
premier mot qui vient à l'esprit
benjamin castaldi tu veux faire mais
pour moi non pour moi légende
[Applaudissements]
j'avais dit à un plan
c'est ben haim c'est d'élégance ça c'est
vrai qu'avec des femmes élégantes ici
moi moi j'avais dit à grandson et s'auto
franzen cgc pour ceux qui savent pas
cyril s'est fait passer pour moi auprès
de kelly renan quoi c'était quoi kelly
des semaines des mois et des mois je
tiendrai des mois j'aurais pu avoir des
gros soucis et tennis levis c'est que
moi je vais raconter me dit ah ouais bah
ouais j'avoue c'est abusé parce que il
ya eu d'autres filles à qui tu as fait
ça comme kelly en faisant passer son
toit donc pour toi n'ont ni croule merci
tu vas nous aspergent assurément non
payés
je veux que les gens ici depuis combien
de temps quoi d'ailleurs chou c'est qui
a lancé un event je crois moi je crois
c'est qui non c'est mon père encore
il faut savoir un truc c'est que cyril
et vos pairs ils sont presque plus potes
que nous devons savoir des vidéos on
écoute je dis tu peux venir faire un
petit truc c'est un peu l'allégorie de
ma vie ça y est toujours mon père qui
débarque de quelque part oui tu sais pas
près de s'arrêter
c'est quoi cette histoire c'est juste
qu'aujourd'hui quand artiste tu doit
aussi gérer tes réseaux tu dois gérer
tes clips tu dois gérer le business tu
dois gérer les concerts ya plein de
trucs tu dois faire et tu dois fait tu
dois être sûr twitch oui exactement
quand tu te tais toi tu es un temps
j'adore je fais vraiment avec holly on
fait tout tu vois c'est ça hec et et si
tu veux ça te laisse beaucoup moins de
temps pour l'essence même de notre art
qui est faire de la musique entre frères
chez à 2 dans une grosse timonerie
succès tous deux chavanne ça nous manque
de sharan est que les animaux c'est
est-ce que tu serais capable de le
refaire aujourd'hui ou plus du tout a
changé d'avis tu pourrais plus faire ce
que tu viendras du par c'est le jeu et
l'autre par la réglementation et tél je
suis soufflé pardon mais là aussi je ne
sais pas qui avait quatre bornes entre
oui j'ai changé d'avis donc je vous en
parlerai j'ai évolué comme la société
comme le public comme tout le monde on a
fait des trucs absolument formidable on
a fait des ddd truc probablement que je
ne ferai plus du tout mais je ne
regrette rien en tout cas voilà alors je
passerai pas toujours veillé à ce que ça
se passe très très très proprement très
on va on va voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma chanson sa chanson pour moi cette
chanson qu'elle a écrite pour moi kenji
conquistadors ce mandat je n'en
demandais pas tant
j'étais seul à chanter je vais me
retourner chez eux juste entendre les
paroles qui vont me pénétrer
oui je ne joue pas autant
[Musique]
il avait déjà quand je t'adore tu vas
pas aimer mis au monde quand je joue
c'est pour la médaille d'or j'oublie
tout tendues danse
c'est comme une évidence
ça va
j'ai plein de la patience
allez bye live
et là il a
la can
cette formule est
ce
la patience
allez on y va
là il a une
[Applaudissements]
c'était attendu c'est oui vous ne rêvez
pas entendu comme moi moi j'oublie tout
quand tu sors temps c'est là bas que
j'ai pas de yake zinc ne voit les coups
y assistèrent henrique jour avoir parlé
avec comme député libanais sait pas
calculer de fruits je le prenais qui
parlait même mois où celui qui tirait tu
vois pas où vous changera pas il
expliqué au quotidien il apte à ne pas
presser émission la fin la fin j'ai bien
compris ne surent pas sur la seule non
mais si
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu peux juger parce que tu nous
[Musique]